The Joe Rogan experience.
I'm too busy for bigfoot ideas.
Yeah,
that's roughly,
and that might've been a real thing.
Yeah.
It was a real animal creature.
There was a real creature called Jack handle [inaudible].
It was a real animal,
just like eight foot tall by Peto.
Hammad absolutely exist.
Probably.
Yeah,
like a giant,
not giant eight due to some sort of guerrilla didn't exist.
Imagine seeing a gorilla,
right?
Like Jesus Christ.
What the fuck is that thing?
Six foot 600 pounds,
king,
huge hairy black beast with a giant chest and enormous arms and pounds on his
chest runs on all fours and you're like fucking fangs.
When they fly through the air at each other and clash.
It's crazy.
Smash into each other and fight.
Holy Fuck Man.
If you didn't know that was real,
I know.
And you ran into a gorilla,
you'd be like,
what the fuck?
And she,
by the way,
they didn't know mountain gorillas were even a thing until the early 19 hundreds
their religion.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
When was the discovery of mountain gorillas?
Don't think they have those giant chimps in the Congo or are hybrid.
No,
they don't anymore because they have DNA.
They're the only chimpanzee species or subspecies.
Cause she'd say that they found that heads a crest on its skull like a gorilla.
1902 bro.
Damn.
Yeah.
A German explore at Captain Robert Vaughn better Inge,
the mountain gorilla was named the Great Barrington g in honor of the captain.
Yeah man.
Fuck.
Looking at,
imagine that thing.
How about those?
That guy who was an anti poaching agent,
he helps,
uh,
protect gorillas from poachers and he got them to pose standing up in a selfie.
And even better,
there's video of him tickling the gorillas and the gorillas.
Laughing,
laughing like a person too.
That's crazy.
So was there a,
a big foot?
Fuck yeah,
there was a big flood.
Yeah,
it was a real thing.
That's why there's so many stories about it.
And it probably died off 100,000 years ago or something,
you know,
every meat or that just,
they're just vegetarian.
No,
gorillas are,
we are closer to chimpanzees than chimpanzees or gorillas.
Is that true?
Yeah.
Wow.
Well,
the,
I think it's interesting in Goma where those groups of mail chimps expand their
territory,
they kill other males to move their women and children into the area that they
annex.
Yeah.
Isn't that crazy?
Vicious?
They just as groups fall down,
fall on the smaller,
you know,
tribes of,
of chimps and decimate them.
They have so many,
so many similarities to humans.
So many,
yeah.
But these,
um,
Bondo apes,
they call them.
This is the,
um,
the giant chimp.
There's these neat,
they nest on the ground to like gorillas.
Are they as violinists?
They live in large communities like chimps,
the little boy,
the locals have two names for chimps over there.
They have one that they're called tree beaters.
Those are the regular size chimps.
And the other ones they call lion killers.
There's so big,
they've,
they've got videos of these things eating a leopard.
What?
Yeah.
They don't know if it,
yeah,
there are enormous champs.
So they don't know if it killed the leopard or if the Lebert died and then
they're eating it.
They don't know what they do.
No one was eating a fucking leopard.
So you gotta think Yummy Kitty cat when they're standing up.
They're taller than me.
I'm five eight there are six feet tall.
You're six feet tall.
Yeah.
So the your height.
Yeah,
your height,
but a chimp and a Jack Champ.
God,
it's probably 250 300 pounds.
Well,
they say they're 400 pounds.
The ones in that they have some in,
I don't believe Kansas City Zoo.
No,
I don't believe they do.
I think they do know they have two giant chimps.
If you look at it as big chimps,
those are just big chimps.
They're huge.
They're like they do.
They've had chimps that are over 200 pounds.
The ved,
some enormous champs,
but they've never had one of these,
did this.
They live in a very specific area of the Congo,
but they've seen them.
Yes,
they have video of them.
They have photographs of them.
You can see videos and UC camera trap photos.
There are real animal.
It's a really big animal man.
It's a really big chimp.
It's amazing.
Imagine to see at a six foot chimp.
No Dude.
No,
I'm,
they'd know.
They eat your face in your genitals.
No thanks.
Imagine standing there,
you turn a corner and there's a chimp as tall as you looking at you disaster.
Yeah.
I have to go low.
If you ever see,
yeah,
you're not going low.
It doesn't matter which one was that.
Do what they had up.
There was a traveling circus when they had a a chimp and they would muscle it
and they'd have any man,
the biggest man that just to hold the chimp down for six seconds.
If you could do that or three seconds and no man has ever able to do it.
They just worse,
there's just,
this is hotter than 50 pound chimp.
Yeah,
and you wouldn't even,
even if it was muzzled man,
it gets to rip your arms off.
Like what are you doing?
Yeah,
you're made out of Jello.
I've you ever held a,
I've held a small one.
A baby one I held,
it was playing with my puppy and it was,
I was his back felt like would,
would,
yeah,
like what,
like perfectly describe.
That's exactly like Dan Henderson probably feels exactly like that.
Hadn't been,
he's,
he's gotta be part chimp.
Yeah.
But I had a two one two year old,
one once a on a fear enough your factor news radio.
And when we're on the set,
the scene actually got cut out.
We never wound up using the scene,
but there was a guy who was like an animal trainer and he had a couple of
different animals with them and one was a baby chimp in diapers.
And this baby chimp got on my back and beat beat on my back a couple of times
and I was like,
what the fuck?
It was like you hitting me.
I was like,
wow,
this fucking little tiny thing just wailed on me.
She said they're so strong through it.
Yeah.
They're a little,
bodies are just hard,
like corded no neck take crazy punishment.
Yeah.